today is a special day for all of us
it's thursday when jesse finally does
his laundry what yes you smell oh but
it's also fox news's 25th anniversary
it's a milestone but it's probably a
bigger achievement than anyone in this
industry would care to admit
because it includes destroying the
legacy media so why in hell would they
celebrate the things that killed them i
don't blame them while we celebrate our
25th what can cnn celebrate
another month without a jeffrey tube and
zoom call
congrats
when fox news debuted it was roundly
mocked but within months the mockery
stopped the critics saw fox rise to the
top and beat the pants off him which was
easy with tubin
so how did this happen
[Laughter]
first it was necessary it had to happen
the mainstream news not only refused to
serve most americans they felt they
didn't have to they controlled the
narratives and you had little choice but
to take it they abused your trust they
lied to you they thought you were stupid
they shared the same brain so the
industry devolved into a corrupt insular
machine out to stoke division to make
money then fox came along we were
different we knew this monolithic media
was derelict in its duty so fox provided
the balance that was missing it did so
fearlessly knowing that it would paint
targets on all of our backs but its
popularity grew and why because we're
people we weren't perfect we were human
you could relate to us it wasn't a
network it was a relationship oh you
could get mad at us and turn us off but
you also knew we had your best interest
at heart so he stuck with us through all
the
great stuff and the not so great stuff
fox didn't speak down to you like the
pompous gas bags at other networks we
spoke directly to you we assumed you're
as smart as us if not smarter we didn't
see family or religion as a joke we
celebrated the american idea we relish
providing a voice for the unheard
as employees at fox we thank fox for
keeping us employed
here's my first appearance on fox uh on
the o'reilly factor i was quite a
handsome guy i have to say
and then there's uh jessie yeah i had
great sideburns jessie those eyebrows
and then there was dana look at her oh
yeah yeah there's there you go you've
been the most painful i think yeah you
aged better than all of us yeah but the
real thanks goes to you the viewers who
trust us and let us into your homes and
thanks to everyone who came before us
who made this happen against seemingly
insurmountable odds to another 25.
great why thank you well said why thank
you well done brother oh thank you
you guys can keep just complimenting me
i'll do that so um
any theory dana as to why fox news
has been able to over time build and
build and build as
such as as the other media becomes more
and more kind of elite and insular well
i think well you nailed it right that
the
media for so long
um basically had a point of view and
it's the mainstream media has kept that
point of view for the most part if not
even becoming slightly more even tilted
towards the left like not so much in the
center even center left but more uh
progressive and then all of a sudden
there was an alternative and you give
people choices in a capitalistic system
then if there's a
market for the product then it's going
to do well what i thought was really
interesting today is that there are 136
employees that work here still today
that started um on the first day wow and
this morning there was a scroll all
across as you can see it there um they
listed all of the people and i thought
that was pretty amazing for for a
network that was supposed to fail yeah
and rupert murdoch in one of the
interviews he did with neil cavuto not
too long ago he said that everyone
thought he was crazy yeah when he was
starting it and so hopefully he's
feeling pretty good today about
the success yeah i remember when it
started in wanting to work for it when i
was at men's health magazine jesse uh i
made the point of comparing and
contrasting the fact there's no
interesting people on other networks i
mean you could you're considered
interesting for the wrong reasons
but do you know i mean there's something
about the fact that if you if you turn
on fox you know the people there because
and you actually when they when people
see you on the street they believe that
they know you yeah well
we have true believers here at fox news
we don't get on the air because we want
to look pretty
and be liked by certain people
and succeed in the broadcast industry we
come on here because we care about the
country and we care about the people of
the country and i like to think that i
speak for the people of the country and
give the people of the country a voice
that they didn't have before so when you
see an audience member approach you they
treat us like family
and that connection is so strong
none other
broadcast professionals have the
connection that we have with the
audience and i can state that as a fact
because we care so passionately about
what we do greg we were talking in the
green room about
a fake news article that we saw that
fake outrage a performance art no
we actually care about what's going on
in the country and maybe we're outraged
at something we see
because that's just doesn't sit well
with us because we know it doesn't sit
well with the rest of the country
but we're also laughing and joking and
it doesn't always have to be about
outrage we're not doing this for money
or ratings we actually believe what
we're saying and that's a lot different
than the other people you see
on television but the ratings are great
the money's good that's because we're
authentic
and you do look good
yeah we have a team of people in here
and they make us look good judge when
did you first come to fox i i think it
was in 2008
[Music]
um i was um i had been the d.a and and i
i ran for attorney general and i didn't
win in new york oh that's me yeah that's
me as a d.a wow war on terror there i
was as a d.a
and uh
i don't know we all look quite different
uh
but at the same time i mean what jesse
was saying and what you've said what
we've all said is this look we resonated
with america and were it not for fox
there would be such a monolithic train
of thought
where all the networks said the same
thing all cables said the same thing i
mean it would be fascism at this point
and the truth is thank goodness for fox
that we're allowed to say what we want
we are who we are we have distinctive
personalities and i agree with you you i
when i go around the country mom i love
you judge jeanine and i'm like do they
they don't know me but they do
and they get that we're honest that
we're believers we're believing what
we're saying and and you got to give
credit this is a david versus goliath
this is a story where you've got rupert
murdoch who had the vision the business
sense he didn't run with the pack he
didn't need permission he didn't need
approval and 79 months of of of a
quarters that we've won and we're number
one that's it i mean that's the american
way there you go harold you're new to
this company but you've been around here
and what do you what do you make what
what is the power of fox news coming
from like outside and coming in so i
actually started here in 2007 i lost a
race for the senate back in tennessee
and started note 7 was here for about a
year however when the network started i
just got elected to congress and your
viewpoints are right we live in a big
diverse sprawling democracy sometimes a
brawling democracy and i think the
cornerstone of our strength as a nation
is that we have to be willing to not
only listen to but accept dissent
political point of views different
political point of views and a new
member of congress i came on this
network often i came on with bill
o'reilly i came on with hannity i came
on with others around the network and i
often wanted to be able to reach
constituents of mine that might not
watch the other networks look i listen
to fox and now that i'm on fox i clearly
listen to it even when i'm not on and my
some members of my party don't like what
happens here i don't always agree with
the things that we talk about but
sometimes i do but you have to listen to
understand when you do and you also have
to listen i think as you think about
crafting arguments strengthening your
own arguments but even more so agreeing
when someone is right and i think we
could all benefit from that and when i
think of fox that's what i think of when
i congratulate mr murdoch and lachlan
and the entire organization on 25 years
of enormous success they figured out the
marketplace and hopefully there's
another 25 to 50 years of success as
well yeah i'll be 60 then
[Laughter]
still look great though amazing yeah it
is amazing with the
well it's going to make a disgusting
joke but instead why ruin this moment
and just move on hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else